we really need to have a conversation
and hear about judgment the far majority
of you will not go home today and start
posting more on Instagram and LinkedIn
and Facebook and Twitter not because you
don't get I love what people I carry I
didn't grow up with this technology I
don't get it I'm like that's nice sooo
you didn't grow up driving and you
figured it out it is very cute that you
tell me you didn't grow up with this and
that's why you don't get it I am wildly
smart enough to understand that you are
bright enough to spend two hours on an
app to figure it out the reason you're
not posting we're doing is because
there's insecurity about what you're
gonna say you got your prospective happy
don't you want to be happy
[Music]
the fact that we sit here in 2020 and
the maturity of the social web and these
opportunities and there are still two
platforms right this second that
requires zero dollars for you to start
communicating what you want to happen
in the world I think is remarkable that
doesn't even take into account the fact
that Facebook ads YouTube pre-rolls this
new Spotify ad product that is gonna
have hosts read live reads like the old
radio game for podcasts Facebook or
Twitter or Twitter's appropriately
priced but everything I just mentioned
to you the ads are under priced the cost
of spending a thousand dollars on these
platforms to get people to see something
is underpriced I really am desperate
with even the tone and tenor that I'm
bringing to this talk I'm desperate for
people to understand how wild this is I
want to remind everybody for everybody
who raised their hand in the first group
like myself the way you built a business
or brought awareness if you're 43 and
older in the way we grew up was by
spending a lot of money ads cost money
Direct Mail newspaper radio ads
television that cost of money it was a
very high cost of entry to build brand
brand is the whole game I think when I
analyze what's going on in the business
world and with people I think most
people are transactional I believe how
many people here are entrepreneurs raise
your hands I believe the majority of the
hands that just went up that when I look
at the Delta between the ones who've won
and the ones who've won less than
they've wanted to I put them always in
my mind into two groups one one group is
transactional aka deeply care about the
money in the short term and the second
group is looking to build brand aka
reputation in perpetuity and are more
concerned about playing it out in the
long term what is exciting for me right
now is that this device this device like
the fact from this young man down and up
every one of us has a device in our hand
that is a computer that is actually more
powerful than the computer that Ronald
Reagan had when he was running the free
world it really is interesting it really
is
III think again what I'm really trying
to establish in this talk this afternoon
this morning is I don't think people
have quantified the opportunity I
struggle regardless of circumstance when
with people dwelling or complaining in a
world where the Internet is free has no
idea who you are could care less it's
right there and it becomes a game of
skill not necessarily finances to
actually win it's interesting to me it's
interesting to me that you can be in the
retail business overnight by setting up
a Shopify account which costs nothing
when that same action to sell something
30 years ago meant that you had to sign
a lease and build out a store and rely
on the local traffic that walked by it
scares me and excites me but the biggest
music company in the world Spotify was
built in Sweden by a kid and on and on
and on and you've heard every story but
more importantly for every ridiculous
story we've seen of Instagram or
Facebook or uber Spotify there are
hundreds of thousands of stories of
people with winds that are the micro
versions actually think the most
unhealthy thing in entrepreneurship and
opportunity is the big stories that
everybody thinks they have to build a
billion-dollar company I think we do not
talk enough about the practical $150,000
a year $300,000 a year $700,000 a year
business that you genuinely love what
you do and you can live your life being
happy and financially sound and what the
cost of entry to be able to do that is
in today's environment which once again
let me say very slow between putting out
a media company if you decide to put
that on a wordpress or a Squarespace a
retail company on the back of a Shopify
you could start a radio show that is
global on the back of just uploading
something you record on your mem
was on your phone and uploaded on to
Spotify and Apple and SoundCloud my
friends distribution is free I know it's
a nerdy thing like it's not like some
big profound statement but let me say it
nice and slow
distribution is free it used to cost a
fortune now what you put inside of it is
the variable of your success not your
financial capabilities to create the
distribution you have like I wish we
could zoom in I literally have
goosebumps on my neck right now
number really I really do it's like a
very I I will live my last breath trying
to get people to understand this is
remarkable this is this is a game of
perspective are you educated or capable
of seeing it from the lens that I'm
speaking about today which is the
barrier to reach the end person whether
you're a financial advisor and trying to
get to a client whether you sell bow
ties whether you want to be how about
the fact if you want to be a
professional football player and now
there's all these websites where you can
upload your film because the Scout
didn't come to your tiny tiny town and
now you actually can be discovered like
everything has changed my question and
my dream every time I speak is can I get
one person in this room to get their
piece for me if you are not
disproportionately happy sitting in this
room professionally which will trickle
into your actual life you have to take a
step back and understand this
perspective so I think we're living
through the greatest era ever for
opportunity I think it's on the back of
the current internet which is wildly
visual I'm very aware that the audio
revolution of our society is coming what
do I mean by that is how many people
here have a Google home or an Alexa in
their house just raise it high I'm
curious raise it high I want people see
this Google and Alexa look around it's a
real number now granted most people are
just telling jokes with their Alexa or
listening to music
but I want to remind everybody that the
first killer app on the iPhone for the
first year was that app that looked like
you were drinking a beer if you remember
it takes some time for the apps to catch
up to the platform but we are all very
close to being in an era where we order
a pizza or where we get our plumber or
how and where we navigate by talking to
a voice device not to our phone as voice
becomes the platform and less happens on
this which seems foreign now because we
all live in it but I want to remind you
we used to not live in it and I want to
remind everybody here technology likes
to move when when not if when you start
doing a lot of things that you do on
your phone right now start happening on
a voice device it will no longer be
visual and written which will lead to
less opportunity to grab attention to
the current opportunity landscape which
I'm going to remind everybody is quite
remarkable because if you've got a local
bakery now and you can do a really good
job on LinkedIn and tik-tok for free or
on Instagram with money when in a decade
we go into voice and I say Alexa send me
six muffins
to the office Amazon gets to decide
which muffins come to the office now if
you did such a good job building brand
and I knew about Carol's muffins and I
said Alexis me6 Carol's muffins to the
office you've now accomplished your task
I spend one hundred thousand percent of
my time on Brandon
I want people to know my name I want
people to know the name of the things I
do vaynermedia my agency when we killed
mr. peanut yesterday which a lot of you
heard about that is us doing brand that
makes you think about planters weren't
thinking about it prior to what we did
yesterday we think about it it's all
brand and so I just want you to get your
long tail of it I do and this is what's
led me to the most interesting
conversations of my career because I as
a business
I never thought I would get into
categories like parenting and
insecurities and self-esteem but as
somebody who just spoke all that and has
done that pretty much every day 600
times a day on the internet for the last
decade it has led me to realize wait a
minute there's the other component of
everything I said I can show every one
of you what to do I just sat here and
told you 100 percent not 99 the two
attention arbitrage platforms of our
society right now if every person here
went home and made five to seven
pictures and videos a day on both
tick-tock and LinkedIn within a year
something good would happen for the far
majority of you 99 percent of you won't
post on either once after this talk the
question to me became why that led to
the next part we really need to have a
conversation and hear about judgment the
far majority of you will not go home
today and start posting more on
Instagram and LinkedIn and Facebook and
Twitter not because you don't get I love
what people I carry I didn't grow up
with this technology I don't get it I'm
like that's nice sue you didn't grow up
driving and you figured it out it is
very cute that you tell me you didn't
grow up with this and that's why you
don't get it I am wildly smart enough to
understand that you are bright enough to
spend two hours on an app to figure it
out the reason you're not posting we're
doing is because there's insecurity
about what you're gonna say you go very
deep into who's gonna care what I'm
gonna say what would I say who cares
what I think
or even worse the thing that breaks my
heart the most you actually do post
something somebody leaves a post that
you look ugly and you [ __ ] and fold
like a cheap chair so that's what I
spend my time in now trying to figure
out how to get people to realize that
the judgment of others has zero actual
impact under
they have zero context on your actual
life and how do I get you to understand
that perspective which would then lead
to you speaking and when I think
speaking let me break this down let me
let me take out the other excuse of why
you for yourself and your business
aren't posting not everybody is great on
camera I get that not everybody is so
wildly charismatic and very good-looking
I get it
however on the flip side I am incapable
of writing it's not my natural skill I
struggle with reading and writing it's
not much skill plenty of people here are
incredible writers and it is an
incredible opportunity to go write 6 to
15 sentences together around a thought
on LinkedIn and hit post others can work
in Photoshop and make a picture others
enjoy I don't I grew up in I was born in
the Soviet Union
and grew up in in a very Eastern
European household I think there's like
eight pictures of me and my entire youth
right we didn't take photos so it
doesn't come natural to me on the other
hand there are people in here who took
97 photos on their iPhone yesterday
there are plenty people here who are
great at taking photos my question here
today my friends is very simple when you
gonna start talking what are you waiting
for if you are not communicating you
don't exist I believe that if you are
not communicating you do not exist more
importantly communicate about what you
love what what what scares me about the
long tail of the Internet is I know
there's somebody sitting in here who's
watched every episode of friends ok
deeply loves friends can't get enough in
their own mind of debating Rachel and
Ross loved the show watch it every night
- go to sleep - and I know they make 49
sixty to eighty eight a hundred three
thousand dollars a year doing something
they don't like and I know that if they
started a podcast about friends every
day when they went home instead of
consuming content to escape the fact
that they don't like their job if they
created content around the thing they
love that after 24 36 48 months that a
long could have came netflix and been a
sponsor of that podcast that would allow
them to actually leave that job they
hate and now be a full-time friends
podcaster you don't believe that I
understand that that seems like a
far-fetched story to you the problem is
you don't live my life because I wrote a
book in 2009 called crush it that laid
this out and I get to live the best life
now where I get three to six emails a
day of people that tell me this exact
story whether it's about pickles people
like pickles my pickle so crazy
Star Trek eat eSports don't even get me
started because I used to push it a lot
and people have gone completely and made
real careers in that just stuff I just I
just really really really hope you hear
me today whether it's for yourself
whether you're a top executive in your
organization and the company still does
direct mail or print or still sponsors
the town fair instead of running content
and ads on Instagram and Facebook guys
it's 20/20 and don't give me this not in
my town not in my industry I'm watching
your town your industry and so that's
where at the biggest opportunity in the
history of humankind to do what you want
to do and yet you will continue to find
reasons not to and I think that comes in
under the categories of self esteem and
self awareness I think we need to make
those words important in our society you
can work hard all you want if you're
insecure you're gonna be vulnerable
because the second there's pushback and
there's always pushback in the journey
you won't go there so that's my
framework those are the things I think
about I spend a lot of time thinking
about that and then you know I have a
company that helps fortune 500 companies
navigate that world
and and I see it every day just go back
to the planters thing because I know
it's on the radar today like there was a
real debate if we could get America to
know that mr. peanut was dead so that we
could run the Super Bowl spot that we're
running during the Super Bowl and if we
couldn't the spot won't make any sense I
and vaynermedia knew that the Internet
is real we knew that if you went on
Twitter like we did yesterday the daily
show will pick it up at night and it
will be on all the recap emails this
morning and in the papers and the AP and
the USA Today the Internet is real life
this is fake life
I just and really I'm really going I
know where the giggles come from and by
the way and an enormous amount of people
hate that thought right like I live in
life I know how we are doing such a
great job currently demonizing
technology we hate that the kit you know
my favorite is my friends who are
parents who like you know because they
know where I sit on tech and they're
like Gary you know I'll be hanging out
with them and they'll be like Gary this
tech is terrible and the kids are on it
too much but the second the kid comes
over and bothers our conversation over a
glass of wine they throw the iPad at
that kid like it's the cure to every
disease the hypocrisy that we have
around technology is fascinating we as
humans are incredible at romancing the
past and demonizing the current and so
these were the friends I watch but I
will say this if you were a vibrant
active ambitious human being which there
is zero reason for you to be at this
conference if you're not zero and you do
not for yourself or your company produce
in the ballpark of seven to twenty five
different pieces of content across three
to nine different platforms a day you
are making a fundamental mistake and I'm
gonna say it again
because when you're talking about twenty
five pieces of content a day in a world
where 98% of this room is not making
twenty five pieces of content a year we
have a very big disconnect between where
I sit on this and where you sit on this
I am giving this talk for one reason
because the rock is filming it and I'm
gonna air it in a decade on whatever the
current platform is when it has been
completely accepted that everything I
just said was 100% right
I am zero-interest of you actually
taking the advice I just shared I don't
know you I've got my own problems I'd
prefer it I deeply and I can't you know
I have to go I'm speaking at Harvard
tomorrow so I have to go I have a couple
more meetings certain I gotta go
Dallas - boss Thailand at 1:40 in the
morning and on those kind of flights I
like reading the emails of you saying
hey I saw you and mobile in 2020 is now
imaginary 2023 I finally listened I was
passionate about X Y & Z I did do an
Instagram account or a podcast or a
YouTube show and now three years later
this happened I love that that is the
big win for me in this room but you
won't you won't and I know that cuz I've
lived this life now for a while you know
what is more likely is you're gonna
email me in six years and say I wish I
did
cuz this happened because I was the
leading lawyer in town and this other
person who didn't was not even you know
the emails are funny right Gary I mean
they come in all shapes and forces Gary
I wish I listen to you and you start
reading it because I read because I want
the qualitative feedback to learn right
I heard you'd four years ago at the
Atlanta Business Summit
you said the thing I didn't believe you
I thought you were loud and obnoxious
I'm not cursing today because naggy
asked me but you cursed that turned me
off I'm a Jersey boy you know you know
meanwhile this upstart kid he listened
to you and then my favorite line in
every no matter what is lawyer doctor
real estate but he's not even good at
being a lawyer but he's killing it on
Facebook and he's hurting my business
what do I do now and I smile I smile the
same way that I saw some of the kids on
the field yesterday that didn't go with
Boehner sports that we know we were in
the final two with them and they went in
a different direction I see them I read
for them I'm a kind person my mom did a
good job but I'd be lying to you if I
didn't say when I look at their faces I
smile knowing they made the wrong
decision cuz I love merit I love sports
you then make the right move or you
don't
I've already won by articulate
my thoughts here today either you're
gonna actually use this talk as the
final piece to actually get out there
and finally do this because you cannot
be in this room and not know what I'm
saying is actually right or you're not
and then you lose and then I get to see
you because they're both good I did it
or I didn't do it I both enjoy cuz I
actually love the merit of the game I
mean that so I hope you do it I don't
need you to do it as a matter of fact
I'll get really technical on you a lot
of my smartest friends always ask me why
I do this because if these people start
making content and start running ads
it's gonna be harder for you to build
what you're building Gary and they're
right the feed of Instagram Facebook
Twitter it's just one feed
it's just supply and demand if all of
you start posting that's just more
content less attention less opportunity
for me to build what I'm building that's
what's going so I hope I've articulated
the punchline I don't think I'm supposed
to be doing Q&A now but to be very frank
I don't I
I gave Maggie the no cursing I'm taking
the Q&A so I'm gonna take a couple your
questions right now because to be frank
I think I've articulated my point and it
is the point we have we if you do any if
you know as a terrible student but there
was one class I was decent at was called
history and I finally figured out why I
like history cuz I know that things
repeat themselves and humans are
consistent and I like context if you
listen to my talk right now and
immediately ran home and read a book or
articles about the transition of America
from the radio to the television
everything I just said would make sense
to you my friends we have transitioned
from the newspaper and television to the
internet it happened it's not going back
I'm sorry it's not my fault
it has happened it's never going back
this is why the mainstream media will
always be wrong about their predictions
because they look at the wrong data they
will always be wrong watch it again
they'll always be wrong it's my company
companies why my company's exploding
because they worked with other agencies
for like the Mad Men era they're always
wrong it's based on subjectivity
politics ego we're here I want you to
take advantage of it cuz if you don't
somebody else well there's 330 million
of us out here in this country and seven
point seven billion yes sir
what's your name Brent the company their
personal yes Brent I think you could do
both right like I do
I'm Gary Vee but my family wine business
Wine Library has an account and put the
wines my direct-to-consumer wine brand
has an account vaynermedia has an
account we cross pollinate obviously if
you're a big personality and big comes
in a lot of senses if you're let me
phrase I'm not gonna use big if your
personality that brings value in
whatever shape is form you're gonna see
more following people like to follow
people over businesses but it's all
about value exchange but yeah there
you'll appreciate is but there is no
right or wrong really there's not I I
would say the only thing that you can do
wrong is not being yourself I see a lot
of people scared to actually be
themselves because they're scared who's
watching and they like I hate looking at
all your LinkedIn accounts you've got
like a suit and tie look at all
professional like you think something
Bad's gonna happen if you're normal I
look like a mess up here wearing a tiara
wack sweatshirt like the results always
win and I think a lot of people hold
back their natural self the market
doesn't care in the end somebody may
judge you but the market doesn't care
yes sir
what's your name Tucker okay thanks for
your special next okay that's awesome
well because of you you executed
become sponsors or or have their their
bosses that are entrepreneurs on come on
Thomas and then and then second we just
got reached out to potentially do like a
live a live audience podcast get those
people Pensacola Florida
Stewart Community Institute they reached
out to us about potentially
brainstorming on that idea so everything
you said is yes and no and it's
important for you at this young of an
age to understand that no matter my
level of successes or different people's
levels of experience the punchline is it
may be yes or no the key is to not do
something that you're so locked in that
once you taste it and you realize it's
know that you can't get out the wrong
thing to do with whoever you just talked
to in Pensacola is decide a two-year
deal to do it live there and after the
second one you're like this sucks cuz I
don't wanna do this so you keep
flexibility the audience won't be mad at
you for monetizing they'll be mad at you
for selling out and that's a very big
difference but I think but it's but it's
so exciting right because I go through
this spiel how long have you been doing
it you mean four minutes if I'm correct
with October and you factor in
Thanksgiving and Christmas you're
talking about nine seconds right it's
important for you to see now for them to
get that level of reach out they just
might be good like there is a variable
and everything I've just said you may
love talking about basketball
you might just be boring so you've got
to be self-aware about it but my big
thing is you may be boring but it makes
you so happy like my big thing is people
don't like their jobs or lives and then
they go and consume things to escape and
I'm trying to get them to create to get
happy you may never become Steven a
Smith but if you start a podcast about
the pelicans even if it gets a little
juice maybe some free tickets to a game
now your palm do you like the pelicans
there's a lot better than watching an
entire Aaron Hernandez Netflix
documentary
yeah I had to go there I hate those guys
so dick much I saw Bill Belichick on the
sidelines yes I wanted to punch him in
his face Jets fans you know cool okay
yep real quick a lot of a lot of people
aren't accepting of it let's talk real
quick who's not accepting of it correct
the people the people that aren't
accepting of it are the ones whose
Commission's and margins are getting
affected that has nothing to do with the
end consumer I haven't had a single
competitor ever loved me
[Applause]
well first one pump I'm pumped that
you're thinking about that I mean you're
aware of what i've done with claude and
sheep heart officer do you know what i'm
saying there yeah I mean look I think
you're like even hearing you deliver
that sentence I think for some of the
better and business people in this room
like we weren't talking about culture
twenty years ago like it was just get
the results done so to scale I do
believe you need culture you know at a
thousand people we have offices in
Singapore in London and Chattanooga
Tennessee like you've gotta you've gotta
really have culture I think the fact
that you're even thinking about it
already means you have a shot at it it
means you're gonna throw money at it and
you're gonna have an HR department that
cares about the employees not as a
disguise for the finance team to fire
people
it's just intent like just even hearing
how much you know talking senior vibes
and the crew this is just intent the
reason I always win is because I have
intent my employees first my customer
second me third that's a very easy way
to win in business I think we all know
that's not how most people do it and if
you're sitting here right now and saying
me I'm gonna start this business to buy
a boat to customers because they're the
people that gonna give me money three
employee you're gonna build a very small
business yes sir yep stand up bro
don't freak out
[Music]
no worries
I know you say
yes okay let's play you're 19 which I'm
so thrilled you're you're asked this
question cuz it's super important this
thought that you need to have your life
figured out this age is laughable this
thought that we've created in society
that 18 or 22 you need to know and
you've got it's like we've literally
built society backwards like when you
first get out of the school machine
which Maps zero to real life you're
supposed to go play real life to have a
chance to figure out what you do so I
mean where do you start you start with
what are you consuming and paying
attention to when you have leisure time
do you play video games do you listen to
music do you like to go out and eat
weird food do you like what do you like
that's where you start so what do you
like comment like what are you about
[Music]
good let's start with comic books do you
want to create kind of books do you want
to sell comic books do you want to buy
convicts and flip them do you want to
work at Comic Con all of those things
would be a good place for you to start
cold email and diem 850 different people
that are players in the comic book world
and one of them might reply to you and
that starts your career like you can
literally work for Funko tomorrow you
can literally work for Marvel tomorrow
you could you just have to write 137
compelling emails and DMS and LinkedIn
things what's up for them yeah bro you
can literally do that how whose
forty-three and older we couldn't do
that on it that's not how it worked when
we were coming up the game you didn't
just like say like you know that
actually ironically once in a while I
come across an OG who's like actually I
didn't do that I wrote 800 letters it
took two months for me to get a response
instead of two hours but yeah man I mean
like you know in the comic world there's
the movie aspect there's the actual
skill of it mate like if you go like if
you like the drawing of it you could
look let me tell you one thing about
winners a lot of winners didn't get
there by accident so when you write a
winner an email your favorite
illustrator at DC Comics hey Sarah I
will bring you coffee get your laundry
grind and bleed just to intern or work
at minimum wage just to see how you do
it one out of every hundred of those
people have I hire IRD rock because he
emailed me three times and now he's D
Rock and people like call their video
people D Rock
that's his story I mean love it
I've always been common in the world of
wanting to create content for things but
my ceramic people just wasn't about that
so wanted to say thank you first off for
like kind of being that person to
console motivate me to go so about a
year and a half ago we started doing a
podcast live podcast on Facebook kind of
started taking off we started getting
messages the company started growing
about a week ago we got a contract for
the ayf which is American football in
the Northeast to do all of their camps
and clinics so it's been super awesome
also my name came up for some high
school coaching job so finger-like the
world has been kind of going crazy no
that can't be
and it's just crazy that you know a year
and a half ago I got drunk about this
and now you know this is actually going
on my mouth but my goal is to get into
that and I felt as a coach one day oh
and right now I see myself in a point of
struggling between maintaining the
company and then having it go over into
putting 100
maybe don't try to make the company as
big as you know you can because you
can't allocate 110 percent of the energy
to it you're now looking at the company
from the perspective of as you know an
alpha as a winner as an ambitious young
dude you're like I gotta make I'm
building this you don't have to build it
like so many people in this room how
many people here own their own business
great this is gonna really hit for a lot
of you there's a lot of people that you
can talk to afterwards if you guys see
this man afterwards tell him that bill
companies and they built it let's say
from zero to a million a year or half a
million but take that and they loved it
life was awesome but from a million to a
million five that like screwed it up
like there's a Mendoza line where like
their people don't understand this this
is why I push happiness so much I'm
thrilled that your business now does
three million instead of 1.6 million but
used to love your life at 1.6 and you
hate it now because you're managing or
you're doing this or that or you're
stressing I think you didn't control the
size your business you can also bring
someone in you can bring in a partner
you can bring in a big time employee
that gets bonus on net profits there's a
lot of hacks for you to go at this you
also can be very patient good so then
you shouldn't be stressed if you say
beep how old are you great if you say
I'm gonna be in the NFL when I'm 42
guess what it gets a lot less stressful
when you're thinking in 14-year terms it
gets a lot less stressful when you're
reading when you're not reading other
headlines when you hear some 26-year old
got the look to be the number two on the
offense at the Bengals all of a sudden
you're frustrated don't worry about
anybody else just like those friends
around you they're like nah nah now that
won't work don't worry about the 26 year
old whiz kid who's on Buffalo right now
that has nothing to do with you take it
from forty four forty two is plenty
young to get your first NFL coaching job
you understand our relationship with
time is something we really have to
start talking about in a society
it just it will take a ton of anxiety
out of the system bro in 18 months
you've accomplished more than a lot of
people ever accomplished in her life
gotcha bro yes ladies lady either
whatever what's your name
Rosie okay okay I'm very weird but
people use regulation as excuse to not
do you execute by not talking to those
old dudes very simple
don't look for permission focus on
execution there's nothing more fun my
whole life I was told what I was doing
was wrong it was crazy to launch an
internet site for a liquor store in 1996
people thought the internet was a fad
forget about his tick-tock a fad some of
the OGIS in here no we debated if the
whole thing was at that right and then I
did email instead of catalogs and that
was not smart
what's email and then I bought Google
AdWords and I was spending more money on
Google AdWords than I was spending on
direct mail and newspaper ads and that
was stupid
and then I sat down and started filming
a wine show on YouTube a month after
YouTube came out and people thought I
lost my mind let alone that it was
stupid and then I took all the money I
had in my life that I saved my whole
life and invested in Facebook and
Twitter five years before they became
public companies and all my financial
advisers and family and everybody else
thought that was stupid
I'm only excited when people tell me it
is stupid that's when I know I'm about
to do something smart
yes sir in the back with the wheat with
the wild shirt
Ethan you said you launched yesterday
first day Depok go ahead
it's letter afraid to believe a dream to
pursue degree
okay okay agreed so in a world where
I've got a lot of things in front of me
and as you can imagine this pitch though
much more fun in real life happens 8,000
times a day here's what you need to do
you need to email me I'll read it
tonight because I have long flights Gary
at vaynermedia
you need to put in the title I'm the
dude with the weird shirt that launched
today cuz then I'll see it right I'm the
dude with the weird shirt that launched
today
and you need to articulate what you mean
on the value exchange and then if it's
there I'll fly it in you're good
yes sir will
awesome so my idea for advertising
good publicity and I hand out pieces of
my apparel and then I you have that as
well and at least my hair or shirt or
something
I'll say listen let's shirt on do some
badass in it okay yes yes I love that
yes that is a very good idea
you can definitely give me a shirt is it
a medium I won't wear it get me a medium
and I'll wear it how she do at the rock
you know what Dee rocks right in front
of you yeah he I get 80,000 he gets
eight-thousand it's all screwed up um
d-roc will give it to you right now the
info like do rock set it to attention
Lou and then I'll wear it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
how are you yes Colton Cody okay okay
yeah yep what are you saying what's
happening on LinkedIn how often are you
posting once a week nine a day yep I'm
very aware as you know you can run
LinkedIn ads against people's job
descriptions have you done that yet yeah
yeah I got a great way for you to learn
this I'll give you guys if you guys want
to learn this as well give you the
website it's um gee oh oh gee what's
really pumped it what why I'm really
excited about this is you guys clearly
you're capable can literally this is
crazy you can literally go to Google and
say how do i target specific
professionals on LinkedIn ads enter and
have unlimited ways to figure out how to
do it it's not the tactics it's the
knowledge of the knowledge of knowing
that you can target people on LinkedIn
LinkedIn makes the wreck mail look like
child's play when you understand it then
when you really understand it and you
realize that you have to do different
content for different doctors and
different sectors in Geographic gender
race mindset it gets real gnarly you
understand yeah you can and the way you
do that is you you target a specific
company all the employees and the ad the
piece of content starts does your head
buyer know does your accountant know
like you see where I'm going so what
you're trying to do is get the employees
to forward it to the CFO or the CIO or
the head medical-device spider I don't
know what that terminology would be you
see where I'm going
you can literally write the words to say
does your a cape if you're selling fast
financial-services literally right along
with the video or the PDF or whatever
you want you got to try different stuff
does your CFO know that she can because
you even know that the CFO and that
company is a woman like you can do such
smart stuff people don't all of this is
just like health and wellness would you
like to be healthier and better shape
let me help you eat well and exercise
every day meanwhile people are like ass
implants steroids like apple cider
celery people are looking for the hack
because people don't want to put in the
work yes sir
Michael get out that's awesome
I go to Scotch Plains by the way that's
my favorite other things side hustle
life you could be 20 K year garage
selling on the weekend selling on eBay
if you need some side cash garage sales
the answer to that is yes and no right
first of all back to some of the things
I've already alluded to here back Tom ed
who next time I saw him
notice when I said to him that he has to
reach out to 137 people people come at
me and I Gary I wanted to be a sports
agent and I tried really hard and I coul
Barry how did you go he's like well I I
submitted to three places and like three
like yes there are gatekeepers for
certain jobs potentially for you to
taste
there's also 7,000 of them so a have you
asked all 7,000 that's a be in the world
of content creation and zero startup
cost one could potentially if they can
afford to one of the reasons it's funny
that we're segwaying off the garage sale
thing one of them like one of things
that kill a lot of people's like get a
job at 7-eleven or do garage saling just
to maintain your lowest possible cost of
living so you can start the thing that
makes you happy
and to your point of 25 like 7 years
from now you'll be 32 years old
do you know young 32 years old is Oh
anyway
second part of that is like I have to
get off on the Entrepreneurship thing to
think that her self-awareness always
preach and I've always try to look
inward and self-awareness in a while ago
I still think that on Instagram that I
always hope it is to find out what kind
of person I am you always say correct
yeah that was yeah that's right you
worry course you were of course both
both it long before I came along or
anybody else the nature-nurture thing
has been established so I don't know you
well enough but there's a deep when I
was five it was not necessarily that my
parents we were very poor and immigrants
but I still thought it was more fun to
go shovel people's driveways when it
snowed then build a snowman because I
wanted a dollar that was my chemicals
then I was conditioned because when I
was eleven and said mom everyone's
getting Nintendo she said great go buy
it I was like all right not gonna work
you know like so for you potentially
it's the complete opposite which is
amazing maybe you didn't have those
chemicals and then on top of it you had
the great fortune then there's nothing
wrong with that we none of us picked our
paths where you were fed so yeah it's
probably more unlikely that you want to
go and grind it at zero and build
something for yourself and deal with all
the fear and anxiety and loneliness and
grind and dirt and blood that comes
along with being an entrepreneur not the
popping bottles and flying in private
jet entrepreneurs that you see on
Instagram that are completely full of
[ __ ] sorry Jim
you got brother been a huge inspiration
for us we had created a consecration
Congrats my question is yes yes humans
like humans yeah if you like it a lot of
people are very shy and introverted and
don't like the attention from other
humans I don't think they should be
making videos you can real quick cuz I
want to give an answer it will help a
lot of people did you ever see that
interview I had where I came up with the
first time of documenting don't create I
really think people need to think about
that just make people overthink they
think they have like even the way you
structured it you're like free stuff
right you're making everything like
shows or structuring it stop thinking
start making cool get up here
let me get on this side yes ma'am I love
love you grew up in Jersey yeah where
where yeah I know it amazing
I'm listening I can multitask
entrepreneur over here good for you but
but know this
tick tock is a crazy place right now in
a great way in a great way
the in the history I'm I have given the
same advice my whole life I am very
basic you like for how many people here
to follow me on Instagram thank you so
you guys know I love putting up videos
10 years ago a little chubby or younger
version of me saying the same stuff I'm
saying right now so I'm saying that for
the people in the room that don't know
me what I'm about to say matters a lot
in the history of my career the organic
reach thing that nobody knows who I am I
want to talk about Alabama football
nobody knows who I am I'm zero followers
MySpace Twitter Facebook social cam vine
snapchat Instagram LinkedIn YouTube
none not a single platform has even been
remotely close to what's happening on
tik-tok when you post your third post
and 800,000 people watch it now it's
already I don't know if you notice this
d-roc it's already declining because
here comes the content because there was
so much attention
compared to content but you would
destroy it on tick tock yeah if I were
you I would make three tick tocks a day
the way I think you get to the question
they had which is like what do we make I
think you look at what's on the Explorer
like the trending page and and the
biggest mistake people make is they hear
this they go home and it's screwed I'm
gonna do it I'm motivated Gary so a
motivating I'm gonna do it
and they're like save download tik-tok
and are like then they're like now one
two things one back to that crazy
website google it's crazy it's an epic
one you know what works on tick tock
enter read for three hours but way more
importantly consume tick tock for five
hours and then make a decision don't
call your 11 year old niece and be like
what's this taste a thing about she's
gonna tell you from an 11 year olds
perspective you're here for business for
building a breakout you're coming from a
different angle that will help you know
what to make it's what I've been doing
all my life so I don't mean two years
ago I'm like the butt of your old joke
and like right like coddled by parents I
had to completely unlearn that like my
man over there you got to learn it you
gotta now I gave a penis yeah it stopped
and then and real quick I apologize
let's not demonize like none of us
picked our spots like I didn't pick like
hey I'm gonna be born in Russia and then
come to America like let's definitely
not over demonize people that had great
fortune of being in a situation they
just have to decide what they want in
their lives like you know it's we really
need to deploy self-awareness not
everybody's supposed to go on and be an
alpha number one and
something big like there's a lot of ways
to skin it but nonetheless I just wanted
to add that because I didn't want that
theme to get too far away keep going yes
the plan
you know like for free yes there's
there's two people the people that can't
make content people that make a ton of
content they don't know what to do with
it so you thank you so please I do this
is from the charger that we gave you
last night bro I love it thank you thank
you I love you bro um so the search
engine we transcribed all my words into
metadata from every single video I've
ever put out in the history of my life
and then put it into a database and made
it searchable so we have a search engine
on our website I'm still not even
promoting it I still you know what's so
fun about playing the long game like
it's you know you're hardcore enough and
my content that you know it exists
because I promoted it for like one day I
don't even really know where it is I
think it's on my website like I believe
it's gonna be the biggest thing I leave
because the earlier thing I talked about
which was like the voice device yeah of
course I heard um you know the the like
I'm so excited that I'm gonna have an
Alexis skill in ten years that's gonna
allow you to be walking through the
kitchen or in the office and say Alexis
I need to speak to Gary maybe like Gary
what should I do when a manager is doing
this and I'll actually reply because the
data has been structured that's gonna be
rad so that's why I did it that's what
I'm anticipating that's what we're
building and I think a lot of people
going to do that with audio information
I think it's I think what we love speed
there's a lot of things you're doing now
that you said you would never do because
you like speed many of you here
ten years ago said you would never text
you now text many of you five years ago
said that you would never use emojis
this is stupid and now you send poop
emojis
the reason you do that is because of
speed the emoji is literally this is
quicker than okay all of you are gonna
use voice devices in your home in office
because it's gonna be faster that's all
we choose convenience over everything we
don't care about privacy
everybody loves talking about privacy
you guys love talking about privacy what
about privacy what about it
you put your credit card all over the
internet all day long the IRS was
completely hacked every single social
security number in this room has been
compromised what's happened the russians
kidnapped you we don't care about
privacy because it's fake
we love convenience yes sir you look
great pretty sharp bro like that tie
clip I remember yep yep
a huge market and bars everywhere
and so we're deploying capital like
crazy therefore we're raising capital a
crazy and I feel like we thought about
putting traffic net with you they're
like we're gonna have to raise a billion
dollars to do that I don't feel like I
think that but my question is like right
now you'll get successful businesspeople
all bags I'm post on LinkedIn all the
time being like hey this is really
taking off all night you know when I
invest and so we're gonna race day at a
time
to a VC firm hopefully never me Caesar
but the second you do a deal with BC is
the second you lose control I would do
what I said to a lot of people here I
think you've got enough juice going on
right now that you're probably better
off going to an extremely high net worth
individual I'd much rather you take
eight million dollars from a guy or a
gal that is either third generation
wealthy or made it themselves and
believe in you because they'll give you
a lot more control than some kid that
went to Stanford and likes Excel sheets
as much as they'll give you
you could have said 12 you're trying to
what break into this waters we got it
having to Alice they can feel it but I
can't post or really get into it
well I mean it's one thing if you put on
your LinkedIn like I hate this job I'm
looking for a new one no kidding you
wouldn't do that you feel like it would
be disproportionately frowned upon in
your organization if you started talking
about your passion about sports what's
that what's her name
what about getting a different corporate
job I mean here's the good news that's
what you have to do if you're telling me
that the culture within the four wall
like every organization is different
like my company has so many side hustles
going on I'm not even sure if you'll
have their own secret vaynermedia's that
compete with us going on you know like
so I think I think you may need to find
a different place to work like I if you
were my sister over like hey because
this is you know where I'm going how
many places have you applied are you so
passionate and slash unhappy are you
willing to get a job that pays you even
five thousand less a year because you're
gonna eat a little more crow maybe you
know to cook like happiness over
everything but right now if you're
painting the picture you're painting you
have no answer unless you go somewhere
else because it sounds like Sarah and
accounting there's a real issue
yes you should do it anyways if you're
prepared to get fired well great well if
then do I mean if you're prepared to
fire do everything okay go punch her in
the face start with that yes sir
hi Emily I'm sorry health coach okay yes
yes yes it's been super easy for example
I'm the most public private person of
all time like you guys know nothing
about my personal life I post like
trillium piece of content but I drew I
put it in my professional world people
was like Gary I don't wanna do it on
private I'm like you don't even know
what my kids look like I'm like I know
what your kids look like and your
private but you've already pushed them
six times on your [ __ ] Facebook so I
found it very easy
this is my point of view is that it's
not the artificial world that's too much
it's the world period they're incapable
of judgment so if they're appeasing
people on Instagram that's fine they're
appeasing people in real life too that's
why they're releasing Alexis that they
can't afford because they want people to
think they're successful people are
fronting 24/7 365 because they're
insecure and if you're insecure getting
off of Instagram is not gonna help you
why don't we take and the conversation
up a notch and talk about why you care
about your neighbors opinion or your
mom's opinion why so Henderson where you
knowing that's great and I honestly I
think it will be a huge trend I think
we're gonna use technology so much more
than now that there is an encryption the
world always swings I think they'll be
incredible businesses I think they'll be
incredible I think of the incredible
businesses of detox centers where you go
to the woods for four days like I've
actually been doing a lot of work lately
I've never been into buying real estate
but I've started the process of looking
at major cities and seeing what the most
rural one our drive is and what the cost
of the real estate is because I feel
like buying a bunch of trees an hour
outside of like any major city that
literally has no cell service is like a
good business in ten years because
people gonna want it for three days or a
week that's great but there's a much
bigger issue at hand which is are you
capable in dealing with other people's
opinions 99% or not that is because of
the last 30 to 50 years of parenting DNA
and many other variables and that is why
I'm so passionate about the things I
talk about because when you get quiet
and it comes in both forms the biggest
breakthrough I think I've said that I
like almost as the consumer of me is if
you can't hear the cheering you can't
hear the booing I'm sure for a lot of
you that have no idea who I am or
haven't seen before you've seen people
come up today and give me some nice
compliments in my impact I don't hear
that in the same way that I don't hear
somebody saying I'm
oh crap or a snake oil salesman I keep
it not too high not too low and that's
helped me quite a bit and I think the
reason people struggle is you love
Instagram when they say you look real
pretty but you hate it when they say
you're ugly you love it when they say
that's fresh
but you hate it when you see somebody
else having a fresh time and you're at
home people are getting too high and too
low and so we need to have conversations
with ourselves limiting our time on
tick-tocks not going to do it Jim one
more because I saw it up there I didn't
know you four were up there but I love
you so much let's go what's your name
I think he should go to campus and
search Twitter and Instagram in that
ten-mile radius and pay attention to
what they like before you guess I think
you should figure out what the demand is
like always finding the meeting people
is that like tex-mex
is not a thing
so you're gonna break I love that so by
the way that's a great counter and
something I love like the introduction
of something that you know humans like
in one place as long as it's not so
foreign and doesn't hit the palate and I
think that connections a lay-up so okay
so you figured out what you're gonna
make okay I don't think it's smart or
not smart I think it's not smart to put
yourself into a jail you say to yourself
I'm gonna do this in 3 to 5 years is
gonna lead to anxiety do it in 12 months
do it in 12 years oh by the way it all
depends on what the arbitrage is you
might realize after a year wait a minute
why would I open a restaurant where the
leases are too expensive I want to open
up 9 more trucks stay fluid don't create
a Nord start here's what you focus on
let me bring this tex-mex delicious food
to these kids and then let me react to
what happens if that leads to a location
great if that leads to 13 more food
trucks great if that leads to a big
company coming in and making trying to
turn it into a national chain or a
product that's sold by a frozen food
company keep it open because a lot of
people at their young stage make these
arbitrary decisions of three to five
years I'm gonna do that they actually
stick to that and then they don't see
all the other opportunity because
they're on this narrow thing that a lot
of times ends up not being the right
thing awesome thank you guys so much
[Applause]
[Music]